you're not what you see Peter why would
someone I want you to be alive anymore
what are you talking about
code eight two two seven confirmed
subjects closed
[Applause]
I know you like Ava but she's a
liability
you know she's best to breathe I
recruited her at Reynders [ __ ] Haven
I'm good Thomas you keep your head down
kiddo management will be watching on
this you did something bad I wouldn't
have said me of you
who was responsible
company had nothing to do with it you
don't believe that Duke you keep
breaking protocol asked you to marry me
and then you just disappear for eight
years
she's always been Jukes favorite but
she's a loose cannon and a dangerous of
the organization
the ones are killed
I'm a tooth or finger I don't care which
[Music]
I warned you I'm not going to be able to
protect you a second time
you need to rescind the kill order you
know I can't do that this is business
lovely morning for it Ava
but security around my family on high
alert
[Music]
you